hi drew hi everybody uh the first half
of that conversation i was like oh i'm
really relating to that with my
eight-year-old daughter who's going on
14.
but then i'll like never let her leave
the house i've already told her like
there's a college down the street from
our house
everything within walking distance yeah
everybody everything has to be close
believe me i was
those scenes are always the hardest ones
for me to shoot because especially i
love isaiah so much we're so close so
it's that stuff is always the really
difficult stuff
because we hate to have any kind of
strife in our life but you know
apparently it happens with teenagers i
wouldn't know anything about that but
your character doesn't always make the
best choices
and sometimes it's fun to pretend to be
someone
who is unlike you and you can live
vicariously through
but one of the things that really struck
me is that you don't want to stay stuck
you want to keep growing
as a human how do you balance that
reality non-reality
for me especially with annie i think
being a child actor i always sort of
played like
the wise kid who really was a little
ahead of her years and for me
one of the big joys about playing annie
was she had a child as a teenager and
her growing kind of stopped there or she
sort of chose to stop looking and for me
that was really interesting because she
kind of was a perpetual teenager
and she's she's kind of the spontaneity
of the group she's kind of
the reason they do the crazy things that
they do
and so i really love that about her but
i also of course love
anything and any character for me there
has to be some form of growth and so for
me that's been a really fun part of this
character is sort of just
somebody who's a little reticent to let
go of the things that have kept her safe
and kept her feeling light and fun you
know um
so that's that's been a a fun journey
because i think normally my characters
are like i'm so spiritual i can't wait
to see what's on the other side as
opposed to this girl who's kind of like
i don't want to grow up past 17. well
speaking of growing up we both grew up
in the business what's it like growing
up in the business for you i i
think it stunted and advanced to me at
the same time
it is exactly kind of a mix of what you
say i think in some ways you grow up
around adults and
there's a serious maturity that happens
there quickly and luckily you know my
family was very
devoted to trying to keep me a child and
make sure that i didn't feel pressured
into doing anything and they were very
cautious about it the whole time it was
always something they were almost a
little like
are you sure you want to do this and i
was like yeah but i think
like what you're saying you know in a
lot of ways i became really comfortable
growing up with adults and
you do become over the responsibilities
of being an adult really early on and
you know while other kids are sort of
like
well let's go to the mall or whatever
kids do
and you know you're kind of like i'd
love to but my call time is 6 30 like
that's real that's what
i have to do this whole school thing and
everything else is a little
um i'm not so sure anybody even cares so
i think
in that in that regard then for example
fun fact i can't ride a bike and this is
something my dad's going to kill me for
because he thinks i'm always blaming him
for this but
i can't ride a bike straight up and
i think so in in certain ways like i'm
terrible
with laundry i'm not a really great cook
i don't understand
certain like normal home person human
being things
but then there is this experience inside
you that is it's almost really difficult
to explain i mean it's a very specific
upbringing in a very specific tone so i
wouldn't treat it for the world
but i do think it's fascinating now that
i'm in my 30s and really delving into
deep therapy
just seeing oh that's that's interesting
those are some interesting
things i never would have noticed you
know it's just a whole different
upbringing
i'm freaking out i really am having an
aha moment
because i've talked to a lot of people
who grew up in the business but i
haven't thought of it
in the parallel of it's true like
you have to be at work at 6am when other
kids are going to school
but then when you're on a set there's a
lot of things that are done for you
uh and so you
don't grow up and learn things as fast
and by the way
god bless anyone out there who dates
male actors of a certain age because
oh my gosh like
whoa it's like they can't get their own
coffee
my where's my wooden steak and girls and
lick and all that
and then i feel bad because i'm like oh
god i wouldn't want someone to look at
me and think
actor because i know
it's happened believe me i've had guys
tell me oh i would never want to date an
actress and you're like
uh thank you but there is a
certain everything gets taken care of
with actors and yet if you're a child
actor
you are responsible you are bringing
home the bacon you're paying the rent
sometimes for your family
you're showing up to work on time you're
rehearsing learning lines
there is it is such an odd mismatch
dichotomy that's almost where the cross
comes in again is you're catapulted into
adult responsibilities
while like weirdly living a very
bizarre life where
now as an adult i almost have this like
running ticker tape i'm like a total
workaholic i think i use it as a defense
mechanism sometimes because i'm like
i'd love to look at myself and make
myself better but gotta go to work you
know
and i think there's like a real tendency
to just like
work work work because you i don't think
you quite understand
knowing how to get home and turn off and
and
understanding what's work and what's
play and what's rest and i think even in
the best
of scenarios of growing up in that
industry in that way it can be
really confusing so then when you get
older you're like i mean
when i didn't work for all this time i
was just sitting here being like ah
must put the stuff on the fold the
towels again because
my must it's my job you know so i think
it's it's been interesting to kind of
take those pieces apart and see what i
can let go and what's just childhood
anxiety trying to keep me safe you know
you're right and i thank you for being
another human trying to figure
out life and yourself in a profound and
wise way good girls airs sundays
at 10 pm on nbc
you